a new era has begun the age of the
Transformers is over don't you get it we
don't need you anymore
[Music]
my family
[Applause]
hey youtubers it's Charlie and the
newest trailer for transformers 4 age of
extinction just landed and it's all
about transformer jousting or at least
that's what this but makes it look like
no seriously though it's gonna be
awesome
it also gives a lot of good background
on the humans vs transformers plot
that's going on in the movie obviously
Mark Wahlberg and the Transformers are
on one side in the human psyche you know
kelsey grammer and stanley tucci are on
the other side the consequence of their
kind of infighting being that the
transformers from space come down there
have been a lot of Unicron teasers as
well as Nemesis Prime but it actually
kind of looks like Galvatron based on
the face gun that he has I really love
the shot of Optimus Prime's sword it
kind of makes it feel like they're gonna
use the Dinobots like horses and it'll
just be transformer jousting it does
seem like they're going to introduce the
Dinobots like antagonists just like in
the original cartoon before they win
them over to their side they're all
calling this a teaser trailer so I'm
hoping that whatever full trailer comes
next
we'll have more information about the
villains I am expecting it to be
Decepticons but there's also been some
rumors for Predacons which is something
they haven't used in the movies yet I'd
say if you're looking for some good
backstory to kind of refresh your memory
watch the original transformers movie
the one with the Unicron I feel like you
can't have a Transformers movie without
Megatron so hopefully as Optimus Prime
is reborn you know via Mark Wahlberg
then Megatron will be reborn as
Galvatron let me know what your favorite
moment from the trailer was but I am
really thinking that you know
transformer jousting would be a really
awesome way to redeem any awful moments
in the movie couple other big things
coming today we got another big Captain
America trailer coming later tonight
I'll post that and then I'll post my
agents of shield review normally this
would be you know Marvel Tuesdays but I
guess you could kind of think of it as
transformer Tuesdays too but be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff it's
gonna be really awesome there's a lot of
new Winter Soldier clips right now click
here for my last transformers trailer
and click here for my last Captain
America trailer thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in a little
bit high fives
you